E
AFGHAN PEOPLE LEFT BEHIND MAKE
THIS A DEBATE WITH NO END IN
SIGHT.
>> ONE YEAR AGO, THIS WAS THE
DEADLY AND CHAOTIC CULMINATION
OF EFFORTS BY THE PAST TWO U.S.
PRESIDENTS TO WITHDRAW FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
THE TALIBAN HAD OVERRUN THE
COUNTRY.
THE AFGHAN MILITARY AND
GOVERNMENT HAD COLLAPSED.
SAPPED OF AMERICAN SUPPORT.
THE BIGGEST U.S. BASE IN
AFGHANISTAN, BAGRAM, ABANDONED
BY U.S. FORCES VIRTUALLY
OVERNIGHT.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD
STRUCK A DEAL WITH THE TALIBAN
TO HAVE U.S. TROOPS LEAVE IN
MID-2021, AN AGREEMENT PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN ARGUED FORCED HIS
TIMING.
>> WE WERE LEFT WITH A SIMPLE
DECISION.
EITHER FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE
COMMITMENT MADE BY THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION AND LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN OR SAY WE WEREN'T
LEAVING AND COMMIT ANOTHER TENS
OF THOUSANDS MORE TROOPS GOING
BACK TO WAR.
>> LIKE TRUMP, BIDEN WANTED OUT.
STAYING, HE SAID, WOULD LEAD TO
A FOREVER WAR, WHICH HAD ALREADY
COST ALMOST 2,500 LIVES, AND HE
ARGUED ENDING IT WOULD ALSO END
THE EXTRAORDINARY COST THAT HAD
RISEN TO $2 TRILLION.
REPUBLICANS LIKE CONGRESSMAN
MIKE McCAUL OF TEXAS, BLASTED
HOW THE WITHDRAWAL WAS HANDLED.
CALLING IT A STAIN ON BIDEN'S
PRESIDENCY.
>> THE EVACUATION WAS SO POORLY
HANDLED THAT WE JUST LEFT SO
MANY BEHIND.
WHETHER IT BE AMERICAN CITIZENS
OR AFGHAN PARTNERS.
>> THOUSANDS OF THOSE AFGHANS
REMAIN, OFTEN HUNTED, McCAUL
SAYS, BY THE TALIBAN.
MORE THAN 74,000 AFGHAN SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISA APPLICANTS ARE IN
THE PIPELINE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SO FAR
HAS ISSUED OVER 15,000 VISAS.
>> IT'S A BROKEN PROGRAM.
IT'S CONTINUED TO BE BROKEN.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION MADE A
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT TO HELP WITH
THAT, TO HELP SPEED UP THE
PROCESS.
>> MANY ARE AFGHAN WOMEN TRYING
TO GET OUT.
AS THEIR RIGHTS ARE TORN AWAY BY
THE TALIBAN, AN ISSUE THAT
SENATOR JEANNE SHAHEEN HAS
FOUGHT FOR FOR YEARS.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN BE DRAMATICALLY
RESTRICTED, THEIR ABILITY TO
WORK, TO GO TO SCHOOL.
>> WITHOUT THE AMERICAN MILITARY
THERE, SHAHEEN SAYS, THE U.S. IS
HAMSTRUNG IN ITS ABILITY TO DO
MORE.
AND THE AGREEMENT THE U.S.
STRUCK WITH THE TALIBAN TO NOT
HARBOR TERRORISTS, SHE SAYS, IS
EFFECTIVELY DEAD AFTER THE
LEADER OF AL QAEDA WAS FOUND TO
BE LIVING IN DOWNTOWN KABUL.
THE U.S. DRONE STRIKE THAT
KILLED HIM, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SAYS, IS PROOF
THAT SO-CALLED OVER THE HORIZON
MISSIONS FROM OUTSIDE
AFGHANISTAN CAN WORK.
BUT THE U.S. INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IS SEVERELY HAMPERED
BY NOT HAVING AMERICAN EYES AND
EARS ON THE GROUND, ACCORDING TO
THE CIA'S TOP FORMER ANALYST ON
AFGHANISTAN, BETH SANER.
>> WE HAVE A GROWING TERRORIST
THREAT IN AFGHANISTAN.
I WILL SAY, I THINK WE NEED TO
KEEP THIS IN PERSPECTIVE.
IT'S NOTHING LIKE WHAT IT WAS
BEFORE 2001.
AL QAEDA IS STILL A SHADOW OF
ITSELF.
WE STILL HAVE THAT ABILITY TO
TAKE THEM OUT.
>> A THREAT THAT RAISES CONCERNS
OF AN ATTACK IN THE UNITED
STATES.
THE HEAD OF THE FBI, CHRIS WRAY,
SAID EARLIER THIS MONTH.
TODAY, AFGHANISTAN IS SPIRALING.
FACING MEDICAL, HUMANITARIAN,
AND ECONOMIC CRISES THAT ONLY
FURTHER FUEL THE FIERCE DEBATE
OVER THE AFGHANISTAN WAR AND ITS
CALAMITOUS ENDING.
A DEBATE THAT WILL CONTINUE LONG
PAST THIS FIRST ANNIVERSARY.
WHILE THE PEOPLE IN AFGHANISTAN
ARE IN SUCH DIRE ADMINISTRATION,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SAID IT
WILL NOT BE RELEASING THE $7
BILLION OF AFGHAN ASSETS FROZEN
BY THE U.S.
HALF OF THAT, SO ABOUT $3.5
BILLION, HAS BEEN DESIGNATED FOR
HELPING THE AFGHAN PEOPLE.
BUT